regardez de qu'on reparle aujourd'hui
alienware on parle du n 15 du n 15 de
cette année n 15 qui était présenté au
cs début 2019 alors un nouveau n 15 avec
surtout une nouvelle carte graphique à
une 15 assure booster et justement ça
mon avis voir plein de points hyper cool
et je suis très content porte voix
parlée aujourd'hui
[Musique]
la bête ressemble à ça alors tout
nouveau alienware n 15 de ce début 2019
ils ont présenté à vegas avec cette
nouvelle carte graphique c'est la nvidia
geforce rtx 20,84 graphic booster pour
plus de performances ça c'est une
machine qui est vraiment cool parce que
elle a plusieurs avantages alors bon
déjà c'est pas une machine qui est donné
donné mais ça je vais vous en parlais
juste à la fin c'est un produit qui est
très léger il fait 2 kg 16 pas très
épais il fait pas plus de 17,9
mm on a un ordinateur qui est fabriqué
en aluminium qui lui confèrent ses
propriétés de solidité de légèreté ne
serait ce que pour ça c'est franchement
cool en design c'est vrai que
franchement elle est super jolie vous
retrouvez toujours ce petit logo
alienware ces espèces de triptyque est
très sympa forme légèrement incurvée son
côté là si vous regardez vous avez aussi
une petite partie qui est un petit peu
incurvé la alienware fait toujours des
super beau produit alienware qui est la
partie qui la mare gaining de dell
produits qui sont toujours hyper bien
finie vous avez plein de grille
d'aération sur le côté sur le dos de la
côte est est bien évidemment
complètement en dessous ça je vous en
parlais dans quelques instants mais d'un
point de vue purement extérieur c'est un
produit qui est vraiment très très beau
et lorsque vous louerez c'est exactement
la même chose
très belle finition clavier qui
complètement rétro éclairé impôts et
venir paramétrez votre rétro éclairage
pouvez choisir les couleurs vous
retrouvez l'éclairage au niveau de la
tête de la ligue 1 est enfin très sympa
belle finition niveau de la grille
également avec des haut-parleurs stéréo
sur le côté pavé tactile qui est super
cool clavier qui franchement très
agréable au niveau du retour de touche
et l'écran qui est hyper sympa lors d'un
écran 15,6 pouces et du full hd c'est
une dali ps qui est assez lumineux
aliens main nous donne à 300 candelas
par mètre carré
c'est cool ici une petite webcam en
eiffage des donc franchement pour des
parties de gaming pour communiquer avec
vos amis comme il est là vous serez pas
déçus on a donc affaire à une vraie
réussite technologique au niveau de la
décale très beau boulot d'alienware à
les nourrir bon c'est la référence à une
des références en termes de gaming on
s'adresse pas aux cochons gamer on
s'adresse plus aux hardcore gamers qui
veulent vraiment une machine pointu qui
va vraiment répondre dans toutes les
circonstances
on a noté le core i9 de huitième
génération overclocké à 5 gigas 16 giga
de ram ddr 4 à 2666 mégahertz
en réalité il s'agit de
barrettes de 8 gigas comme il est là
j'ai la version avec un ssd de 256 giga
et bien évidemment cette fameuse carte
graphique nvidia geforce rtx 20 80 avec
la technologie imax qu design et lui j
md mois gddr 6 une bécane performante
puissante qui répondra franchement à vos
sollicitations
on pourrait envisager d'augmenter la
rame en option on pourrait envisager
d'augmenter le ssd 512 1 tera intéresser
un peu mais 500 doussal franchement et
au niveau de la batterie c'est une 60
watts qu'on pourrait monter jusqu'à une
90 watts l'autonomie dépend franchement
des jeux auxquels vous allez jouer si
vous allez consommer énormément si vous
allez beaucoup sollicité la machines
alienware nous donne en 17 heures en
mode inactif et 10 heures en mode
lecture de vidéos ça va vraiment
dépendre de vous ça va vraiment défendre
de vos usages c'est un peu compliqué de
vous dire vous allez regarder ton temps
si vous êtes un hardcore gamer
si vous jouez des choses vont vraiment
demandé de la ressource l'autonomie sera
moi là si maintenant vous êtes sur un
visage un peu plus cool des jeux peu
plus soft vous allez garder un peu plus
longtemps vous rapprocher des 10 heures
ça va vraiment dépendre de vous
puisqu'on parle de performance puisqu'on
parle d'autonomie on va parler de bruit
parce que c'est une machine qui est
susceptible de se faire entendre
êtes vous rappeler à ses bons souvenirs
lors de sessions de jeu très exigeant
alors je vous rassure c'est pas déconner
on n'a pas une énorme soufflerie à côté
nous ça fait mais elle vous rappelle
quand même que derrière elle un double
ventilateur et qui carbure et ça paraît
assez logique puisqu'il est là pour
refroidir la machine qui est de son côté
va tartiner pour vous satisfaire
et justement côté refroidissement à la
technologie thermique triotech v2 et
franchement elle fait vraiment bien son
boulot au-delà de l'aspect purement
technique moi ce que j'aime vraiment ce
produit sont les finitions des légères
bordure du côté de l'écran bien
évidemment ce look toujours très
prononcée très gamer alienware
c'est une vraie belle réussite et d'un
point de vue purement esthétique
s'arrête le produit franchement et super
top
autre point qui est cool ce sont les
connectique un port jack micro un port
ethernet 3 ports usb dont un qui est
compatible power cher vous avez un port
thunderbolt 3 usb type c vous avez un
port aliens graphique en plis fire vous
avez de l'âge des amis 2.0 du mini
display port 1.3 un port d'alimentation
et c'est vrai qu'en termes de
connectique franchement vous avez de
quoi faire autre point qui est très
important et qui est hyper appréciable
c'est le retour de touche
je trouve qu'il ya un excellent retour
de touche le clavier est vraiment hyper
hyper hyper confort et en plus ce qui
est vraiment génial c'est là
vance du pavé numérique ici son côté
pour des grandes sessions gaming vous
avez de quoi faire la qualité de l'écran
est bien ce qu on pourrait
éventuellement regretter c'est de ne pas
avoir un écran 4 k et un écran tactile
après est-ce qu'on a nécessairement
besoin je suis pas sûr franchement comme
il est là déjà en full hd les cool il
est lumineux et il a un taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 m
ça aussi franchement ça fait la faire
monter une expérience en termes d'usagé
ce que je retiens c'est la fluidité
ça va très vite ça réagit directement et
quelles que soient les jeux que j'ai pu
mettre derrière j'ai absolument aucun
souci et pour moi c'est tout l'intérêt
de cette machine au delà du côté spectre
de la du bel écran au delà tous
anglettre on peut faire ce que je trouve
génial c'est qu'au final cette machine à
elle vous paraît transparence lorsque
vous jouez pas ce que vous en rendez
même pas compte c'est fluide c'est
pratique on peut comme je vous le disais
est reproché le fait qu'on pourrait
aller encore plus loin au niveau de
l'écran on pourrait espérer quelque
chose d'un peu plus silencieux avec
encore une plus grosse autonomie mais
comme il est là franchement il fait l
affaire alors justement je voulais vous
parler du prix c'est une des cales qui
coûte 3000 299 euros vous pouvez
rajouter des options alors les options c
est sur mon ordi ils sont listées à côté
on tourne sur windows dix familles si
vous voulez passer sur un windows dix
professionnels il va falloir rajouter 74
euros 40 au lieu de 16 giga de ram si
vous voulez passer à 32 giga de ram va
falloir ajouter 230 euros et si vous
voulez passer de votre batterie de 60
watts à 90 watts qui coûtera 25 euros de
plus
après il ya plein de petites options
logicielles mais c'est vrai que moi ce
que je vous conseillerais déjà ces deux
grilles d un petit peu votre batterie 60
watts 90 watts pour 25 euros vu déjà
pris la machine à mon avis faut pas trop
se poser de questions
son nouveau lleno rn15 est disponible
soit en couleur gris qui s'appelle les
pics silver ou alors en rouge c'est le
rouge nébuleux vous m'en direz tant pour
résume un peu expérience machine cool
design racé ça c'est pas nouveau de la
part d'alienware ce qui est vraiment
intéressant là dessus c'est la montée en
gamme au niveau de la carte graphique la
geforce rtx 20,80 toujours plus fluide
toujours plus rapide ça c'est
franchement cool une bécane qui est pas
destiné à tout le monde un très
clairement les personnes qui vont aller
acheter
cette machine là ce sont des hardcore
gamer des personnes qui veulent une
machine performante qui pourront
utiliser pourquoi pas s'ils veulent
faire du montage vidéo vous aura
absolument aucun problème là dessus pour
faire tourner première ça ça ira super
bien une bécane
vraiment exigeante moi en tout cas je
peux vous la recommande et je trouve
vraiment bien
je sais pas vous ce que vous en pensez
qu est ce que vous pensez gars y'a du
renouveau cette année chez alienware il
ya aussi un nouveau produit qui a été
présenté tout au début de l'année il ya
une nouvelle écriture au niveau de la
gamme
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
dites-moi est-ce que vous aimez la
marque d'émile de dell est ce que vous
la trouvez intéressant parce que vous
êtes un gamer quel type de gamer vous
êtes qu'aux joueurs gamers hardcore
gamer et est-ce que vous verriez
l'intérêt d'aller acheter cette bécane
ce m15 vous invite à embarquer tout ça
en banque au mental sachez qu'il existe
également le n 17 si vous voulez un
écran beaucoup plus grand et beaucoup
plus de confort alors forcément qu'il
est plus grand plus galère à transporter
mais bon après pourquoi pas ça dépend à
près de vos usages je vous invite à me
marquer tout ça en commentaire moi je
trouve cool à lormont voulait pas du
court parce que je retourne jouer j'ai
partie est terminée vous embrasse à
bientôt ciao